voici espace la nouvelle arme secrète de
la régie renault premier constructeur au
monde à commercialiser dès juin prochain
le véhicule de l'an 2000 espace n'est ni
une berline traditionnelle ni un break
ni un véhicule utilitaire aménagé c'est
tout à la fois en termes techniques il
s'agit d'un mono core autrement dit
d'une coque unique constituée en
polyester et profilés à l'image d'une
motrice de tgv
propulsée par un moteur longitudinal de
2 litres situé à l'avant espace dépasse
allègrement les 5 80 kilomètres à
l'heure avec des accélérations à faire
pâlir les berlines de haut de gamme du
marché français pied au plancher entre
deux radars la consommation n'excède pas
les 12 litres aux cent c'est la grande
innovation originalité également dans le
fait qu espace peut transporter jusqu'à
7 passagers
les sièges s'enlève en quelques secondes
et pivote dans tous les sens espace
devient alors un véritable salon ou
plutôt un restaurant roulant d'où son
nom
bon appétit messieurs n'oubliez surtout
pas le mini beurre et la télévision
le tout avec des dimensions extérieures
qui n'excède pas celle de la renault 25
dans l'immédiat seule une version
essence sera commercialisée à court
terme après apparaîtront des modèles
turbo diesel avec en prime quatre roues
motrices espace préfigure d'ores et déjà
ce que seront les voitures de la fin du
siècle et la nouvelle philosophie de
l'automobile
[Musique]